4pm may 2014
you refresh the school page again the
essay results are due any second now
you hold your breath in panic you sent
that essay in last minute you wrote the
whole thing in two hours
refresh
your friend is sitting next to you just
as anxious and god knows why
you're a bit annoyed by it actually
because he worked on my essay for six
weeks he'll be fine refresh
why are you like this when are you ever
going to be able to work like a normal
person and stick to the schedules
refresh
they're out
you got an a
what you got an a
your friend got a c
oh this this is awkward your your
frustration is replaced by relief but
also discomfort and insecurity damn
they've worked so much harder and longer
than you this is not at all a rare
scenario if you're also a chaotically
passionate person like me you might
recognize that super focused super
speedy work that you can do last minute
and still get amazingly good results
and then only get told off by the whole
world and yourself for not being able to
be consistent in the first place if
you're kind of chaotic you probably
recognize that super intelligent super
focused version of yourself that shows
up to do work last minute
and yet you and me probably for a very
long time have completely ignored that
person or hated that person and tried to
turn ourselves instead into someone who
can stick to habits and be consistent
and i've just found that this is a
terrible idea because i fully believe
that habits and consistency are
absolutely not essential to long-term
success and also we do not need to have
the panic of a last-minute deadline in
order to turn into very focused and very
passionate people but what if i found
something that is not anxiety that then
helps me to turn into this super focused
and passionate version of myself for
every task that i need to do wouldn't i
be much more happier and effective never
having to create habits at all because i
have gone from time to be consistent to
embracing my complete inner chaos and
crucially never doing work that i don't
want to do and genuinely in the long
term this has led to so much better
results and i believe is the only reason
that i'm able to maintain this youtube
channel by myself while also being a
medical student and having to do a bunch
of other things so let me try to explain
fully why we should never work when we
don't want to and how to organize things
in kind of the way that i see the world
so hopefully if you're like me this
might help let's get straight into it
the first issue that i find with the way
people approach work is that they see
all work as being one and the same and
this is generally not the case for me i
divide work into two different types
real work and arbitrary work real work
is something that has to be done on a
deadline that is set by someone else and
that i can't influence for example i
have an exam at a particular date or i
need to send in a project at a
particular date or i have a team meeting
at a particular time these are things
that cannot be done according to my
feelings i can't finally decide at 2am
that i want to have a meeting and invite
people to a zoom call and in the same
way if you have a baby that's crying and
they need food you need to address that
right then and there so these are real
deadlines and i think the advice of just
get things done and ignore your
motivation works perfectly for this you
have no choice so you have to do the
thing that is absolutely fine however i
think there's a whole other side of work
that is bundled up with this and just
doesn't belong there and this is what i
call arbitrary work arbitrary work are
things that i schedule in my calendar
but that i need to do in my own time so
for example if i have an exam in may
between now and may i have a whole bunch
of studying that i need to do by myself
and that can be done essentially almost
at any time or i have three or four
projects i need to hand in a year for
university the work to do them is done
in my own time and because i have a very
project based job a lot of the work that
i need to do is also done in my own time
so this is called arbitrary work these
are things that i know i need to do have
no strict external deadline have to
absolutely get done but it depends on me
when these things are done and in what
state they are done now depending on the
stage of our life we might have less or
more real or arbitrary deadlines for
example when you have a baby the amount
of real deadlines you have is extreme
because you can't depend on your mood
when to feed the baby or wash them or
change them etc you need to deal with
them when they want to and for example
when i was a waitress all my deadlines
were real deadlines i couldn't depend on
my feelings or just give people food
later when i wanted to because it
doesn't work for me right now however at
this stage of my life because i'm in
university and because my work is very
project-based i have a huge amount of
arbitrary deadlines and very few real
deadlines so if you also fall into this
category this video might be useful for
you if you have only real deadlines i
don't think this is going to work i'm
afraid accepting that real work i do
whenever i need to do and that's fine
i've just accepted it focusing on
arbitrary work all of the things that
i'm scheduling by myself
every single time that i need to do
something here if i don't feel like
doing it i will not do it at the time
and i'm going to explain why the reason
for this is that i have accepted that
there is a huge difference between the
performance that i get from a task and
the output that i get on the task
depending on the mood that i am in and
my levels of motivation so let's say
that i have some studying to do tonight
and i'm really really not in the mood to
do this but i've put it in my calendar
i've promised myself it's a good time to
do it i'll just do it anyways i'll sit
down and as i read i feel like a
complete idiot because i'm completely
unfocused i have to read the same
sentence five times i don't understand
what's happening i'm very distracted i
put my fear on and do not disturb and i
try to change my environment and focus
it just doesn't happen i spend three
hours studying but i barely get anything
done
overall this is almost a waste of time
but
imagine for a second that i really
really wanted to read this chapter if i
had the motivation to do this i'm a
completely different person i am
breezing through it i'm going through it
so fast i'm doing exercises i'm excited
i'm asking myself questions i feel like
i'm the most smart person in the world
and i'm getting 10 times as much work
done almost for the same amount of time
that i would be doing in my unfocused
state so
if for a second we could guarantee that
even though i don't feel like doing this
thing right now i don't need to do this
thing right now and i am guaranteed to
want to do this thing in the future it
would make absolutely no sense to do it
now right it would just make sense to
leave it and do it when i feel like
doing it because i can get the same
amount of work done in much less time
and actually enjoy it if we are in the
situation to accept that there is some
work in our life that is arbitrary which
we don't need to do
life or death at that time and if we can
also accept that there is a difference
in our experience and in our performance
when we are motivated and unmotivated
and if we can also then accept that our
motivation for something will come in
the future then it makes absolutely no
sense to do work at this time if you
don't feel like doing it and instead
save it for a time that you feel like
doing it later and although this sounds
really really simple i think the biggest
issue here is well i'm never going to
want to do this thing and i just think
this isn't true i truly believe that i
have to a huge extent an ability to
control my motivation and i've spent a
lot of time trying to understand break
down control and direct my motivation
for different things and the results
from the ability to do this have been
absolutely life-changing for me here's
the example in the beginning of this
video even if you've never intentionally
been able to change your motivation you
probably recognize that when you have a
strict deadline and you have a lot of
anxiety around the task somehow you have
a lot of motivation to do things the
night before and you also realize that
you are so much faster and more
effective at doing a task when you're
riding that huge level of motivation
than you were five days ago when you
technically had time and you still
didn't feel like doing it and even
though anxiety is a very effective way
to increase your motivation i don't
think it's the singular thing and i'm
not arguing for leaving everything last
minute i think there's a whole host of
other things that we can do to change
our motivation levels and this is why as
cringe as it is to admit this the only
reason that i can run this youtube
channel and business by myself is not
because i am super intelligent or super
fast but i'm only working with my super
elizabeth intelligence and super
elizabeth speed at that task at a
specific time i'm not the smartest and
the most motivated person in the world
and sometimes i am the stupidest and the
least motivated person in the world i
just never work in that state i make
sure that every time that i'm doing
something i am showing up as the most
motivated and the most excited and fast
person that i can be and this is how
things work for me take a picture here
and the way that i imagine things is not
that i have this schedule and i am going
to put things in when they need to be
done and just stick to them because it's
guaranteed that a lot of these things at
minimum 60 or realistically 90 of these
things i would be doing just because i
have to in a completely slow and unm
motivated and bad way the way that i see
things is that i have a schedule and i
have times where i can do things i also
have a bunch of projects on the side and
what i do is i match the project with
the state of mind that i am in so if i'm
feeling hyper passionate about something
that's when i'm going to do it rather
than doing it when i've scheduled it in
if that makes sense because as i do this
every day and then every week every
month what this means is almost all
parts of the work that i do for a
specific project are always done when i
am the smartest the fastest the most
motivated and the most passionate
version of myself for that task and what
that means is that i am getting so much
more output for the same amount of time
that i am putting in while enjoying
myself a lot more and this is why
putting in the exact same amount of
hours and the amount of work my output
now is insanely different than it used
to be in the past because i'm not
arbitrarily sticking to things i'm doing
things when i am the best version of
myself to do those things and obviously
this is not a 100 perfect system there
are many many times where i am just
tired and lazy there are times where i
still rely on my last minute anxiety to
get things done and there are times
where i just have to do things in that
board state because it just has a super
immediate deadline or i'm not passionate
enough for something
but there is still a huge change to the
consistent version of myself that i used
to have before and just applying these
principles in general has caused the
biggest change for my life now if we
somehow accept this way of working
here's how i'm going to explain how i
increase my motivation in order to get
things done now the first core and most
essential thing is the realization that
it is work and it is valuable and it is
effective to spend your time increasing
your motivation so i love the phrase
that says give me five hours to chop
down a tree and i will spend the first
four hours sharpening the axe why do we
not do this with work it's absolutely
ridiculous to me increasing your
motivation is sharpening the axe making
yourself angle work in a way that makes
it interesting for you making sure that
you actually want to do this thing that
it's the right thing to do this thing
and increasing your desire to do
something is sharpening that ax and if
we're just being consistent for the sake
of it we're just working all the time
with a blunt axe for no reason and
feeling absolutely miserable i accept
that some people like habits this is not
for them but if we hate habits there is
no point in just showing up with a blunt
axe every single time and i genuinely do
this because i know if i have five hours
to do something if i spend the first
four hours trying to make myself want to
do that thing and one hour actually
doing that thing the results from this
will be much more effective than
spending five hours doing boring work
because if i'm unmotivated there's no
chance that i'm being effective and
there's absolutely no way i'm going to
get creative but if i'm motivated in a
short amount of time i can get so much
more work done so even though increase
your motivation can look like
procrastination on the outside i
generally don't care if it looks like
i'm not working i couldn't care less i
know this makes sense for me and this is
the way that i function so this is what
i do but i'm going to give you four
tools that sharpen the axe or kind of
sharpen my mind and make me more
motivated in order to do something so
let's get straight into it the first
tool is focusing on skills versus
results and i have a full video on this
here so i'm not going to waste your time
if you've seen it already but just in
brief what the basis of this tool means
is that results are not enough to fuel
our motivation because either one we
don't care about the results so
therefore there's no motivation or two
we care about the results but the
process is too boring so we think nah
don't want it anyway or is there another
way to do this and we just never end up
getting things done so what i do is i
completely ignore results and i focus on
skills instead and this means i will
break up the task into its component
parts so writing an essay might sound
boring because i couldn't care less that
my professor will be proud or that i'm
gonna have a great number i couldn't
care but what i do care about is
structuring my arguments better i do
care more about being better at verbal
communication and what that means is
then i can be a better partner a better
friend a better mom a better youtuber a
better person so i can focus on the
skills within the task and that can fuel
my motivation i have very little
motivation for random results that
people tell me to care about i have a
lot of motivation for increasing my
skills and making myself a better person
so i hang my motivation on these things
and this leads me to my second point
which is making tasks work for me this
needs to be a two-way street in order
for it to make sense i feel like a lot
of tasks or projects that i'm given are
just things for me to do and i naturally
very often don't focus on what is the
task doing for me so before i start a
task i will make a task do the work i
will in a way of course this is a
two-way conversation within my own mind
so it might sound a bit crazy but i will
kind of ask myself what are you doing in
return like what are you giving me fine
i'm giving you my time my energy my
focus what are you giving me and this is
where i can lean into these skills a bit
further i can lean into how this task
can improve things that i value in my
life and things for me rather than just
another thing that i need to do for
seemingly no reason so this sort of
focus really really helps the third task
is focusing on the bare minimum and what
this involves is that very often if i
have a lot to learn in order to start
doing something i will just get very
bored with that thing and this can be a
lesson in medicine where it's a whole
chapter on a whole condition and i don't
know anything about it yet and it just
feels really boring or learning
something completely new like how to
edit videos and what i will do in this
case is i will learn very very basic
principles like i'll give myself five
minutes to learn for example three basic
rules of editing like how to open and
how to get started on a project or i'll
learn the very very basics of the
anatomy or the physiology of this part
of the body and then i will go into the
deep end i will spend time looking at
crazy things that people have done with
this for example what patients have
people helped how can knowing this
information on this clinical condition
actually change someone's life or then
i'll look at what crazy edits have
people done in their videos and then i'm
going to immediately get started i'm
going to use just these very basics in
order to try to do these crazy
complicated things and pick up the
lessons that i'm supposed to do along
the way by using only the bare minimum
one you can get a lot farther than you
think you can because people focus on
the sexy moves and the crazy little
details and like little things in
medicine nobody cares if you just know
the very very basics you can get a lot
farther than you think you can with a
lot more general understanding and it
gets a lot more creative as you're using
first principles every time to do crazy
complicated things and you get jump
straight on the task immediately when i
have to do something that's a lot of
work to get started my motivation for it
is very very low but if i know that with
very very few basic things i can
actually get started right now my
motivation for doing that task increases
a lot so exposing myself to crazy
interesting results while using only the
basics to get there tends to be a huge
factor in fueling my motivation and
lastly not to be looked are getting over
mental barriers because realistically if
you have something to do if you know now
is a good time to do it if you know you
have to do it and no one's going to do
it for you
and you're still not doing it you have
an emotional problem this is not a
logical problem the logic is there it's
an emotional barrier so i think i always
do some exploration within myself
questions that i ask myself are what do
i want to do instead why do i not feel
like doing this task when do i think i
would want to do this task what would
make me more likely to do this task am i
somehow insecure what would happen if i
completely failed at this task how would
that make me feel am i certain that i
can do it am i certain that i can do
some version of it am i certain i can
improve at this thing genuinely what am
i worried about if i fail at this task
what part of myself will feel insecure
what skills in myself do i think i am
worse at and if i do this task better
what skills of myself do i think i'm
improving and i'm quite familiar with
things that i'm insecure about in my
performance i'm very familiar with
things that i'm secure about and i'm
kind of very in touch with my fears and
anxieties which might sound like a bad
thing but it really helps me recognize
when they are being triggered in a task
and therefore kind of calm myself down
rationally and then start doing the task
so getting in touch with your emotional
self treating yourself like an adult
understanding exactly why you don't want
to do something is very very effective
so overall what i end up with is this
line of reasoning if there is a task
that i want to do today but i don't
necessarily and absolutely have to do
today i will ask myself do i feel like
doing this if the answer is yes i'll do
it that's fine if the answer is no or
hmm not so sure i won't do it i will
spend time instead motivating myself to
want to do this task using one of these
four tools i know they sound really
organized i've only organized them to
kind of give that information to other
people in my mind they're very natural
and intrinsic and i kind of like use
them little bits here and there i
wouldn't use all four or use them all
the time so i'm going to motivate myself
to want to do this task and motivation
works in weird ways depending on the
level of the task and how i'm feeling so
sometimes it might take me five minutes
and i want to do it sometimes it might
take me five weeks and then i'll want to
do it that's absolutely fine so i'll
invest time and motivating myself to do
that task in the process i might end up
wanting to do something else which is
also fine i'll do that instead or i'll
end up wanting to do that task later but
this is not wasting time this is
sharpening the axe and it's so so so
essential and then there always come a
point where i'll feel that i will want
to do this task eventually and i'll do
it then worst case scenario i want to do
it because of my anxiety which happens a
lot rarer for me now but mostly i can
lean into these positive emotions for
wanting to drive myself to do something
now one thing that tends to happen when
i motivate myself and feel that i need
to start something immediately is that i
often don't learn the complicated things
and because i just use the basics and i
teach myself how to do things the
results tend to be a bit weird the way
that i edit videos the way that i write
the way that i use maths equations the
way that i paint is quite weird because
i never learned the advanced method and
finally after a year and a half on
youtube i've decided to kind of see what
the professionals are actually doing
with editing and to do that i've checked
a class on quick video editing on nebula
classes which has been absolutely great
there's one lesson in this class in
particular that talks about some quick
methods to make your editing a bit
faster and i'm actually quite excited to
use them on this video in particular so
i'm probably going to be checking that
out if you also want to see nebula
classes there's a whole bunch of things
over there i might have my own course
there at some point maybe i don't know
but in the meantime this cast on editing
is absolutely fab would really recommend
it there'll be a link in my description
for a discount for it but otherwise if
you made it so far thank you so much for
spending this time with me i hope you
have a wonderful rest of your day behind
yourself and others and leave everything
you think thanks bye